WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD
AFTERNOON. I AM RESPONSIBLE
COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
SENATE STAFF. WE MUST LIMóN
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE WILL BE HOLDING A
SENSE OF HEARING AND IS VERY
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS AND MORE
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUE TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WHAT CONDUCTING THE
HEARING IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
PUBLIC OF OUR EMPLOYEES
SENATORS. AS COMPLY WITH HIS
ORDERS HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING IN THE
REMOTELY. USING A VIDEO
CONFERENCE SYSTEM. HI. OKAY
BETTER BE HELLO. AN INMATE.
YEAH. I HAVE CHECKED. RIGHT ON
pIS A RESERVE HE ONCE AGAIN I'M
BEING. OKAY THERE ARE. NONE WE
BELIEVE OF WHAT US BATES MAY BE
JOINING FOR MOBILE WE WILL
SEIZURES NOW WITH US YEAH. I
REMEMBER WHO WILL BE ATTENDING
TO PLEASE ME WASHES ON ITS I
WILL NOT GIVE THAT STRUCK. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC I WE BEEN MADE
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC TO ROOM HERE
AND THE SENATE IN OUR GALA AND
THEN TWENTY TO FOR SOCIAL THIS
THING. WELL BE USING A TELECOM
SERVE OF PEOPLE CAN. AND
TESTIFY. FOR IN. WHO WISH SUPER
PUBLIC COMMON. THE TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT HERE IN A MOMENT.
IN ORDER TO PROTECT THE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. WE ARE ASKING YOU
TO TESTIFY USING THE TELEPHONE
SYSTEM AS WELL. THE PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. ONE EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. AGAIN EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE. SIX THREE SIX FOUR IN
THE ACCESS CODE. IS. EIGHT ONE
NINE THREE OH SEVEN SIX. EIGHT
ONE NINE THREE SEVEN SIX. WHEN
WE MOVED THE PUBLIC COMMENT TO
A MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE AND
AT THAT TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS IN
THE ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. NOTE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU PLAY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. UP PLEASE NHI<c.cyan> THE</c>
DEVICE YOU'RE USING TO WATCH
THE HEARING. THAT THAT IS NOT
PLAYING ON THE BACKGROUND. WHEN
YOU GIVE YOUR TESTIMONY. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HERE- HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY.
AND ANY INDIVIDUALS OR
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE. OR
HAVE A CONNECTION YOU TO. I
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE THIS HEARING. AND CONDUCT
THEIR HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO
THIS- MATTER AS OUR NORMAL
HEARINGS. THERE WILL BE SOME
LIFETIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
WERE ADJUSTING TO THE USE OF
NEW ONLINE TOOLS AND
TECHNOLOGY. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENCE AS WE
WORK THROUGH THIS. ONE TODAY'S
AGENDA THAT WE WERE A ROUTE.
THE YESTERDAY AND THAT IS SB
FOURTEEN TEN BUT WE START WHY
DON'T START A- WITH SECRETARY
CENTER WINNER. PRESS WINNER
PRESENT. MORRELL HERE COPYRIGHT.
ZERO HERE. RATHER HERE MCGUIRE
MORAL. MORE LIKE PRESENT ROCK
HERE ROTH HERE SKINNER SKINNER
HERE NUMBER. NUMBER HERE WITH
HEALTH HERE CATHY HERE. NINE
NINE MEMBERS SO WE HAVE FOR
EXPECTED CINEMA WILL BE CHOI US
SHORTLY. OKAY. HAVING A SEVEN
THREE FOUR. WE WILL BEGIN OUR
REGION ITEM ONE SO BILL. TEN
AND THAT IS SENATOR GONZALEZ
AND CALLED WILL BECAUSE THE
BILL BY TODAY SENATOR COMPARED
MAY THIS IS THE- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CHAIR AND- THANK YOU FOR
THE ON. TO SB FOR TEN AS PER
CALL. AS FOURTEEN TO IS THE CAL
EMERGENCY SOLUTION AND HOW PRO.
PROVIDE EMERGENCY AS- FOR THOSE
OWN AND WHO HAVE BEEN NAY NAY.
AFFECT BY THE PROVIDE NINETY
VIRUS RENTAL ON SUPER IN THE
PER. WOULD AGREED ONE EXCEPT 8%
OF THE RAY AND THE REMAINING
PERCENT TO NOT CHARGE LATE.
THREE NO. THE RENT FOR THE
REMAINDER OF THE YEAR. AND FOR
NOT FILE IN THE T. BASED ON
PAYMENT PAYMENT RED RIVER THREE
ANY PERIOD FOR WHICH THERE
EXCEPT. SB FOR TEN IS TO
FINANCE SECURE. AND WELL BEING
OF CAL RENTER WHO BY FAULT OF
THEIR OWN LUSTER HAD SIGNIFICAN
REDUCTION IN THEIR INCOMES AS A
RESULT OF THIS PANDEMIC. I KNOW
THAT THERE ARE CONCERNS OF
AMONG THE OPPONENTS THAT THE
BILL THAT SHOULD NOT BE
VOLUNTARY ON THE PART OF THE
LANDLORD AND WHILE THOSE ARE
VALID CONCERN THE BILL REDUCES
THE AMOUNT. OF RENT AN OWNER
CAN COLLECT AND THERE COULD BE
LEGAL CHALLENGES OVER MANDATORY
REDUCTIONS. THERE ARE NO
PROGRAMS TODAY OFFER RENTAL
ASSISTANCE SUCH AS THIS I AM
CERTAINLY WILLING TO WORK WITH
THE SENATE LEADERSHIP. TO FIND
AN ALTERNATIVE FOR PROVIDE
RELIEF THAT IS MANDATORY. OTHER
PROPOSALS UNDER CONSIDERATION
BY THE SENATE LEADERSHIP WILL
PROVIDE RENT PAYMENTS AND TAX
CREDIT FOR LANDLORDS OVER A TEN
YEAR PERIOD. STARTING IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR WHICH IS ALSO
PROPOSED AS A BOTH A VOLUNTARY
PROGRAM. HOWEVER WITH THE
RENTER'S NEED AND WHAT BE
FOURTEEN TO PROPOSE IS TO
PROVIDE RENT RELIEF SOON.
RATHER THAN LATER FOR OWNERS
WHO CAN'T. MAKE IT AND TELL
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. THE
OPPOSITION ALSO POINTS OUT THAT
THE BILL DOES NOT TARGET OWNERS
INTENDED TENANTS MOST IN NEED
AGAIN GIVEN THE STATE'S
BUDGETARY CONSTRAINTS THAT IS
CERTAINLY A VALID POINT IT CAN
BE CONSIDERED. ULTIMATELY
APPROPRIATIONS HAVE TO CONSIDER
THE PRICE TAG FOR THE BILL AND
CREATE A FRAMEWORK THAT TARGETS
THOSE MOST IN NEED. THE BOTTOM
LINE IS IT ACCOUNT- NOTHING
THIS IS THENUMBER ONE CONCERN
IN MY DISTRICT THE FEAR OF
INFECTION BECAUSE OF THE
ECONOMIC SITUATION IS BECAUSE
BEEN CREATED BECAUSE OF THIS
PANDEMIC. IF THIS BILL WERE
STALLED I KNOW OF NOTHING THE
PROVIDES DIRECT ASSISTANCE THE
CALIFORNIA RENTERS. I WOULD
LIKE TO CONTINUE TO MOVE THE
BILL TO FIND A SOLUTION FOR
THOSE MOST IN NEED. AND DOLLARS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE SOONER
RATHER THAN LATER WE ALL KNOW
THAT EVICTION IS A BIG CONCERN
ONCE THE COURT OPEN AND WE
DESPERATELY DESPERATELY NEED TO
FIND AHLERS. TO HELP OWNERS AND
TENANTS GIVEN IN THE PAST TWO
YEARS THAT WE HAVE SPENT.
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
I HELP THE WHOLE BLASTING WE
NOW ARE. HUNDREDS OF THE- OF.
RENTERS OVER THE STATE
CALIFORNIA. THAT BECOME HOME
BECAUSE OF THIS PEN. I THINK
YOU FOR YOUR- I HAVE WITH ME
HERE TODAY DEBORAH CARLTON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION. AND LUIS ME DANTE
WITH THE TENANT ORGANIZATION
CAL YEAH BE IN SUPPORT. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AT AYE
STERN MR RUN DAYS HERE BY.
PHONE SO ZERO OKAY SO THE BE A
TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES SO. I'M
IS CARLTON OUR YOU. OR THAT
WILL GO TO MISTER MOORE TERRY
SO YOU MAY BEGIN. HOLD ON HOLD
ON ONCE THE YOUR MIKE IS NOT ON.
READY OKAY I THINK YOU SHOULD
HAVE ENOUGH. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I'D NEVER CARL TO THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION WE REPRESENT FIFTY
THOUSAND RENTAL PROPERTY OWNERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND 75% OF THOSE
OWNERS HOME LESS THAN TEN
UNITS- THE COPE WITH. THE
PENDANT HAS BROUGHT FRANK TIME
FOR TENANTS WHO CAN'T PAY THE
RENT AND ESPECIALLY FOR SMALL
OWNERS WHO HAVE MORTGAGES
TAXING UTILITIES TO PAY- FOR IT
HAVING TO BETWEEN. 80% TO RENT
AND NO ONE. SOME HAS BEEN. OKAY
AND WE SURVEYED HAS INDICATED
THAT WOULD FOR IN PRO. TO SAVE
WHEN MORE WOULD RATHER A BIG
JUST DOESN'T COMPORT IT TAKES
TOO IS TOO EXPENSIVE THAT IMHO
AREAS OF THE STATE YOU'RE CAN'T
THAT I REALIZED IS A REAL AHEAD
OF US ON THIS BILL BUT IF YOU
DON'T STATE PROPOSAL THAT WE
KNOW WHAT WOULD BRING BRENT MY
TO RATHER THAN LATER. THE THIS
BILL DOES NOT. THANKS LANDLORDS
IT. THIS CAN'T BE THE M.
RESPECTFULLY WERE ABLE TO THANK
YOU VERY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR AS FAR NUMBER NOW WE'LL GO
I DON'T KNOW IF HE'S ON THE
PHONE LINE OF THOSE RUN TAKE
CALIFORNIA YOU ME MISTER. IRAN.
HE SAYS HE'S ON THE LINE YOU.
CAN WE IF YOU MAYBE IT IS ON A
PUBLIC ACCESS LINE NOT ON THE-
RIGHT. IF YOU ARE AN ONLINE YOU
CAN PRESS STAR AND THEN ZERO WE
CAN UP YOUR LAW AGAIN SORRY
BEEN. ZERO THE. YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HI I DO LUIS CAN HEAR
ME YES WE CAN HEAR THE
RESTAURANTS ARE YOU CAN PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- A GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK TANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE
TODAY ABOUT HOW FORTY INDEED
THE FOR HER AT THE FOURTEENTH
AND- I'M SORRY FOR THE
TECHNICAL GLITCHES THAT GETTING
IN HERE TODAY. MY NAME IS LOUIS
MORON FAN I THE LEAD TO. FOR
CALIFORNIA BE. HOW TO THE
KEEPING MY COME SHORT I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER A QUESTION THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE. A CALIFORNIA BE
ADVOCATES FOR AN A COUPLE
HELPING. AT THE TEN ADVANCE
THAT MEASURE BY CREE AN OPT FOR
RENTAL AND FOR CANADA AFFECTED
BY INCOME WHY DO TO BUT
NINETEEN. THE PROGRAM IN THE
BOND FOR TWO AND THE LAND IT
WILL LIKELY BE POP WITH. ACCESS
FUNDING FOR BY. RELIEF I
TENANTS OUT FAN INTEREST. ARE
SOME THE FACT TOOLS KEEPING OUT
AND AT THE FOURTEENTH AND. FOR
NEARLY RATING OUR HOUSING.
INCLUDING HAD BEFORE. BUT THANK
YOU FOR MUCH THANK WILL NOW GO
TO PUBLIC COM WHERE WE WERE.
ASK PEOPLE THIS STAY THEIR NAME
CONCILIATION AND BECAUSE THIS
AND THIS FIRST OF I DIDN'T IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE GALLERY
HERE I DON'T ANYONE OKAY WHEN I
GO TO ROOM FORTY. AS ALWAYS
IT'S I'M AND THEY'LL GO. OUR
TELL RESIGNED SO FOR THE MARCH.
ARE ANYWAY ON THE- TESTIFIED
AND OF AS BEFORE TIMES. AND I
AM VERY TO SHOW TO OF BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN AND
TIME AGAIN HE SHOWS CORE OF THE
BILL. ONE THEN THERE OUGHT TIME.
YOU HAVE HE AND LOCAL TO THE
FOR LINE LINE FORTY. HELLO HI
EVERYONE MY NAME IS RICK
TEMPORE THE SENATE I'M ATTENDED
ORGANIZER WITH BILL VALLEY AND
A TEN. AND I BELIEVE THE BILL
OF THE MOST VIABLE I'M TO RUN
TO FISH WHERE BUT THERE ARE FEW
FIVE RIGHT THE OF ALL SURE.
PROGRAM OVER WE BELIEVE THAT
THEY SHOULD BE A MANDATORY
PROGRAM ACROSS THE BOARD. YEAH
THANKS NO NOT AT EFFECTIVE
PROTECTION TENNIS NOT HAVE TO
CARRY THE BURDEN SUCH A THAT
BEEN BROUGHT UPON THEM BY
ORDERS GOVERNMENT OR SO HE'S
WERE SO I HAD TO PUT THE BILL
MIGHT BE CONCERNED TAKING A CAN.
IN AMENDING WORKING AND THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
THANK YOU YOU'RE ACTUALLY ON
AND THIS WAS A POOR AND SO WILL
TAKE THAT AS HALF OF THE ON OF
THE TWO FOR THE OFFICE IS THERE
ANY SO MODERATE OR NOT IN
SUPPORT. A POLL YOU HAD PRESS
TO. ZERO TWO TAKE YOUR AUTO
THINK YOU. FOR THE POOR. EIGHT
THE COURT HERE. WE WILL NOW
POLITICAL LINE SEVEN FORD THE
POOR HER ACT THEY LOCAL TO LINE
FOR FIVE AND THE- MR MEMBER
SOVIET BELIEVE SHOP ON BEHALF
OF THE VIDEO PANAMA AND STRONG.
THANK YOU. NOW BUT AND FIVE AND
SUPPORT. LINE THIRTY FIVE
REALIZE BUILD. WELL I'M NOT
GONNA TELL ELEVEN AND SUPPORT.
WELL I ELEVEN YEAR LINE IF OPEN.
ONE I WILL TELL THIRTY AND
SUPPORT AND MAKE A YOU HAVE TO
I NEED TO BE ABLE TO BEAT ON
YOUR END. AGAIN LINE. THIRTY
THREE. YOUR GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARE MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE ADAM.
WITH A CAL CAME OF COMMERCE
TRUMP'S. AND ON THAT GO TO LINE
FORTY FOUR AND SUPPORT. IF
ANYTHING ON BEHALF OF BRIDGE IS
THE PART. I KNOW NOW POLITICAL
LINE FORTY NINE AND SUPPORT.
LINE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND I AND EVERYONE IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE NINE THANK
YOU CAN DO JUST CHECK ONE MORE
TIME TO SIT IN SUPPORT. YEAH
MAYBE EVEN GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW THE OF THE
BILL PLEASE PRESS. AT THE END
AT THE TIME. AGAIN HE SHOWS.
THE BILL PRESS ONE ALL AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE NO ELSE CAN ITEMS.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WILL NOW GO TO ALL. TONY SASHA
HAND IN FROM THE WEST CENTER
LAW POVERTY BECAUSE SOMEONE
THAT JUMP THE QUEUE AND- SOME
OF THE TIME YOU'LL HAVE A. WE
HAVE SUCH A ON THE LINE. IT
FAC CHECK THE IN THE NINE
RIGHT PLEASE PRAY STAR THAN
ZERO WE CAN I YOUR MY. YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
RETURN. GREAT GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M SOFT HEARTED ON THE APPLE
CENTER LONG POVERTY AND THE
HELP ON EARLY ASSISTANCE FOUND
WE ARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE I'M
NOT THE BILL AS AMENDED WE HAD
DOUBLE COMMERCE THE
CONSOLIDATED OFFICE GUARDING
CONCERN THAT HAVE NOT ADDRESSED.
ARE ORGANIZED REPRESENT A LOT
OF CONTENT TO HOUSE ARGUE WITH
OUR TEMPLATE AND THE GREATEST.
RIGHT THAT'S AND ARE IN SPOT.
WE HAVE HOPE AGREE THAT HOUSE
ISSUES AMONG THE CHALLENGES BY
CO THAT. AND WE MUST CREATE BUT
PROTECT THEM UP VULNERABLE.
THESE ARE ON PRESIDENT TIME FOR
REQUIRE PRESIDENT POLLUTION AND
WE KNOW THAT MILLION. RESIDENTS
ARE WITH A HARDSHIP AND MILLION
THE TEN EITHER HOW BEEN WHAT
WILL BE ABLE TO PAY THE RENT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATE BILL SIMPLY
DOESN'T CONTAIN A LEVEL OF
PROTECTION OUR COMMUNITY BUT
CONCERNED WITH TO MAKING
FUNDAMENTAL LAW ONE IF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN OF
REQUIRING ALL THE BURDEN PUBLIC
HOUSING AUTHORITIES AND OTHER
IN THE- GENERAL. THE
OBLIGATIONS AND THAT MILLION
INDIVIDUAL APPLICATIONS FOR
RENTAL ASSISTANCE- BUT PERHAPS
MORE TROUBLING EVEN IF THE CAN
I GET ALL THE WAY THROUGH THAT.
AND ELIGIBLE FOR THE- THERE'S A
TRAP DOOR WHERE THE LAW
COMPLETELY DON'T DON'T WANT TO
ACCEPT THE. BATMAN AND EITHER
ARE. SERVICE MOTIVATE SENATE
THE BUYER THREE VICTOR FOR A
PERCEPTION THAT THEY BE ABLE. A
DEPARTMENT THAT RIGHT AGREED A
LANDMARK MIGHT WANT TO THAT SO
WE THINK THAT WE SOLUTION IS TO
BECOME THE QUESTION OF WHETHER
HOME TO TAKE. FROM WHETHER ON
PAPER RIGHT CAN BE FOR. IF I
DON'T MY PHONE BILL THE PHONE
COMPANY THAT OWNS THE CLIPPERS
THAT THAT THROUGHOUT THE DAY.
WE ALSO NEED TO TRY TO DEPLOY
READS TO SHORE UP THOSE IN NEED
THE HOUSING IS THAT OF BEING.
WALKS COMBINED WELL THE- LONG
TERM TRIGGER CAN IMPACT
PEOPLE'S CREDIT AND I HELP AND
DEAL WITH THIS WITH THIS. WE
THINK THAT COMFORTABLE INSPECT.
ISSUES AND WE WERE LOOK FOR TO
BEING AND ABOUT OF THE. THE
PLOT THAT THEY'LL BE RESPECT.
HI THANK YOU I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE WILL NOW GO TO
ADDITIONAL COMMENT WERE GONNA
ASK TO SAY NAME AFFILIATION IF
ANY AND YOU'RE POSITION I THIS
IS FOR A- OF THE OPENING GALA
IN THIS CHAMBERS I DO NOT SEE
ANYONE SO. WHEN I GO TO. TWENTY
FOUR. AND ONE DAY WHILE SOMEONE.
TWENTY FORTY. WE'LL NOW GO TO
THE- TELECONFERENCE LINE-
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN
THE QUEUE TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION.
AND AS A REMINDER TO UPHOLD THE
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE AT THIS TIME. AGAIN TO
OPPOSE THE BILL PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEY'RE ALL AT THIS TIME.
AND IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE ABOUT
TEN. PINE KEEL OVER GO TO THE
LINE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS BRIAN CLIMB
OUT OF SERVE THE PEOPLE IN BAY.
AREA CLOSE SB FOURTEEN FINAL
TELL MANAGEMENT WELL. SO THANK
YOU. ONE NIGHT CALLED CAROLINE.
FOUR A LITTLE BIT. HELLO MY
NAME IS COREY I LIVE IN THE
TIME OF DAY. I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO SIGNAL MY OPPOSITE. TO THE
MEASURE AND SOME OF THE CONCERN
RAISED BY OTHER TENANT ABOUT.
HIGHER DRESS THE LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL A TYPICAL YOU DON'T.
THAT THERE SHOULD BE AN OPTION
UNLESS IMAGING. SHOULD BE MUCH
STRONGER LANGUAGE PROTECTING.
THANK YOU. ON THAT GONNA TELL I.
THIRTY EIGHT. IF I HAD. HI
EVERYONE MY NAME A BIGELOW ARE
PROMOTING CALLED WILL COME TO
PEOPLE BASS FOUND THEY COUNTY
BUT I AM ALSO WITH ANYTHING
BEING INDEPENDENT- ARM I THINK
I OPPOSE INTO THE BILL IN THE
MANDATE- IN AMENDED MAKE IT
MANDATORY BUILD LANDLORDS HAVE
TO PARTICIPATE IN ALL CAN AND
CAN GET. TAX THEY DEVELOP WELL
AND I MEAN I. PLEASE GO OUT.
LINE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE MEXICO TO LINE TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE CALL HAD. IF THAT
MAY. YOUR LINE IS OPEN IF THAT
MAY. YES HELLO MY NAME IS
ANASTACIO MONOPOLISE I'M A
TENANT IN SAN FRANCISCO I
OPPOSE THIS BILL IT DOESN'T
GUARANTEE TENANT PROTECTION
FROM A BIG SHIP THERE IS MEANS
TESTING OF TEN POTENTIAL
DISQUALIFIED UNDOCK IT WORK
THOSE WITH IN. WHAT DOES BOB
THE BOOK DOES A FAIR BY
ECONOMIC IMPACT THE PANDEMIC WE
NEED RAY READ THE THEM. THE
TENSION IN HER CONCERNS THAT
THIS WILL FAIL TO ADEQUATELY
PROTECT VULNERABLE RENTERS FROM
DISPLACEMENT AT THIS CRITICAL
TIME. THANK YOU. ONE HOTEL LINE
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NICHOLAS RELIEF FROM SAN JOSE
AND I'M A MEMBER OF SHOWING UP
FOR RACIAL JUSTICE AND I AM
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF TENANTS
AND AS SUCH I OPPOSE THIS BILL
UNTIL THE MEN AND AMEND THE
TURF LIKE ALL. TURNS WELL NOT
PHOTO LINE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ZERO HI MY NAME IS
MEREDITH CHARLENE I'M FROM
TAMPA BAY AND A NUMBER OF
SHOWING UP REGIONAL JOB. I'M A
HOMEOWNER CALLING QUIRK OF WHAT
THE TENANTS HAD. EXPLAINED AND
AYE OPPOSED NO UNTIL IT AMENDED
TO REFLECT CURRENT- INTENDING.
THANK YOU. WELL I'M NOT GONNA
TELL LINE ELEVEN PLEASE CALL I
HAD. HELLO MY NAME IS CAROL
EVEN WHEN I RETURN HER GRANDSON
OR CERTIFICATE HEART I PUT THE
BILL AND CHALLENGES AMENDED TO
REFLECT- THE CONCERNS THAT ARE
BEING MADE BY HAND AND- WELL IN
MEXICO TIMELINE THIRTY FIVE
PEOPLE HAD. WHAT CANDIDATE I AM
I ALREADY HAD TO REACH IS NOT
PART HELP MUCH FREE WHO ARE
RICHARD AND I A CREDIT THE BILL
FOR THE REPEAT STATED THAT THE
RENTAL COULD EIGHT VENTURES TO
BE HEARD AND. BOY INCORPORATED
INTO BILL THANK YOU. ONE I GO
TO TWO PLEASE CALL I HAD. MY IS
MICHELLE CALL I'M FROM JOSE AND
THEN OF UP FOR RACIAL JUSTICE
I'M A HOMEOWNER FOR YOU CAN AND
I OPPOSED TO BILL UNTIL IN. TO
REFER INTENDED CONCERN. ONE ACT
GO TO LINE. THREE CALL. I THANK
YOU EVERY ON THE RUNNERS AND
LOOKS WILL COME VERY DE AND WE
SHARE THE CONCERN ON THE BALLOT
INCLUDING THAT THE BURDEN FALLS
ON TEN AND IT NOT BE UNIVERSAL
TO ALL TEN WE ALSO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE CALIFORNIA.
ASSOCIATION OF THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE. VOTING DOWN THE PROPOSAL
TO TEMPLE. THAT WOULD LOCAL
DISCUSSED AND NO VOTE ON THAT.
POSTED ON. TO PANIC. ONE I GO
TO LINE. NINE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WELL THE NEXT
GOAL TO LINE FORTY AND- HI MY
NAME IS LOUDER THE S. MARK AND
I THEIR CONTENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS OF THE
PEOPLE SAN JOSE AND SOUTH
BETWEEN LANTERN. I AM A
HOMEOWNER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
UNTIL THIS IS AMENDED TO
REFLECT STRONGER TENANT
CONCERNS AND PROTECTION. WELL
NEXT GO TO LINE FIFTY ONE LEGAL
I HAD. EIGHT YES MY NAME IS
TREES OF SLANDER AND I'M
CALLING FROM SAN FRANCISCO I AM
A- AN ADVOCATE FOR SENIORS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AS
WELL AS AN ADVOCATE IN MY
COMMUNITY IN NORTH BEACH AND I
AM CALLING IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL AS IT IS CURRENTLY
STANDING AND- THERE ARE
AMENDMENTS MADE. TO REFLECT
TRUE CAN I PROTECTION I CAN'T
SUPPORT THAT YOU NIGHT HOTEL
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE TWENTY SIX YOUR OPEN.
HELLO HELLO YES I CAN HEAR YOU
THANK YOU MY NAME IS KATHY
LIPSCOMB AND I'M A MEMBER OF
SAN FRANCISCO SENATE UNION AS
WELL AS A MEMBER OF THE- OUR
DISABILITY- FORUM HERE IN SAN
FRANCISCO. I DO APPRECIATE THAT
THAT SOMEONE IS THINKING OF
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN TO
TENANTS I MEAN THE FACT THAT
NOTHING REALLY THAT'S GOING TO
COVER ALL TENANTS IS
PROBLEMATIC SPECIALLY CHANCES.
ARE MOST IN THE NATION THIS
BILL IS OBVIOUSLY VERY
DIFFICULT. SHOULD MANAGER AND
THE PEOPLE WITH A- GREATEST
POSSIBILITY DOES IN THE
INFORMAL ECONOMY AND THOSE WHO
ARE UNDOCUMENTED ARE THE ONES
WHO MOST NEED TO ACCESS SUCH A
BILL BUT BECAUSE THEY WANTED
THEIR LANDLORD MAY NOT. BECAUSE
IT'S NOT MANAGER IT HAS TO BE
MANDATORY FOR THE STATE FOR THE
ALL STATE BOTH TENANTS AND
LANDLORDS I THINK. OUR
STATIONED ACTION. SO GOT SHOULD
BE CHANGED AND ALONG THE LINES
SUGGESTED BUT IT HAS. TO IT
CERTAINLY HAS TO COVEROF A
HAVE NO YOU OF PEOPLE THE
STREET I MEAN IF SENSE TO NOT
TO EVERY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR LISTENING. AND WE HAVE NO
ONE IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THEY GIVE A LITTLE MORE
LATITUDE- FOR THE- FOLKS TO SAY
THEIR PIECE BECAUSE WE HAVE
THAT ON THE OTHER SIDE AS WELL
SO TRYING. TODAY YOU JUST CHECK
ONE MORE TIME TO SEE IF THERE
ARE ANY OPPONENTS. AS A
REMINDER TO OPPOSE THE BILL
PLEASE PRESS THE WINE AND
THEY'RE ALL AT THIS TIME. AGAIN
ONE THEN THEY'RE ALL AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. OKAY
THANK YOU SO THAT WAY I'M
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BRING IT
BACK TO. THE COMMITTEES- DO ANY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ABOUT AS
THE FOURTEEN TIME CENTER MORE
LOCK. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. I
WANT TO THANK. THE AUTHOR IN
THE PRESENTER FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND FOR CLARIFYING
THAT THIS IS NOT THE TEN YEAR
PAY BACK PLANNER THE TWENTY
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS. ECONOMIC
RECOVERY SO THANKS FOR
CLARIFYING THAT I AM. I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT A FEW ISSUES
THEY WERE BROUGHT UP- BY THOSE
THAT PARTICIPATED IN THE CALLS
AND- PHIL THE FIRST IS. THE
ADMINISTRATIVE CONCERNED
SOMEONE MENTIONED A MILLION
APPLICATIONS WE'VE WE'VE BEEN
DEALING WITH THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT.
RECEIVING APPLICATIONS WORK
WE'RE DEALING WITH IT AS
LEGISLATORS ARE HEARD THE LAST
NUMBER WAS THAT SEVEN THOUSAND
CALLS A DAY COME FROM OUR
OFFICES TO THE E. D. T. THE
HELP CONSTITUENTS FILL THE EDT
IS A MESS. DMV WITH A BILL
IDEAS BEEN A MESS- EVEN THE
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS TRYING TO
GET. STATE FUNDS THAT'S BEEN A
MESS- SO I AM REAL CONCERNED
ABOUT. WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
AT THIS PROGRAM IS IMPLEMENTED
WITH THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. DEPARTMENT WE'RE
LOOKING AT SOME KIND OF
MANAGEMENT TRANSITION. WHAT
KIND OF SOFTWARE. I'M JUST
CONCERNED SIDE I'D I'D LOVE TO
HEAR. HOW WE'RE GOING TO RAMP
UP FOR SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
THAT QUESTION- LET ME JUST SAY
THAT THAT- THIS REALLY IS A
WORK IN PROGRESS WE STARTED OFF
THINKING EIGHT CD IS A PROGRAM
THAT THAT. WORKED WELL IN THE
EIGHTIES CD WE'VE GIVEN THEM A
LOT OF WORK TO DO OVER THE PAST
COUPLE YEARS AND THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO HAVE THE BAND WITH AND
SO ONE OF THE AMENDMENTS WAS TO
ALLOW THEM TO. PARTICIPATE AS
A- AS A PARTNER WITH NON. IT
MAY MAKE MORE SENSE TO GO TO
LOCAL. ORGANIZATIONS IN EACH
ONE OF THE COUNTIES BUT BUT LET
ME JUST SAY THAT WHENEVER
YOU'RE DEALING WITH A PANDEMIC.
AND YOU'VE GOT THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE AFFECTED
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE AFFECTED. IT'S ALWAYS
GOING TO BE A CHALLENGE. TO
IDENTIFY WHAT PART OF
GOVERNMENT IS GOING TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE ON THE RESPONSIBILITY
TO HANDLE A LOT OF PAPERWORK.
AND THE AND THE- OVERSEE. MAKE
SURE ANY IS ACTUALLY GETTING
WHERE IT SHOULD GO AND SO- WITH
THAT IN MIND ALMOST ANY
ORGANIZATION THAT WE CHARGE
WITH THIS KINDS OF KIND OF
RESPONSIBILITY IS GOING TO HAVE
A CHALLENGE BUT I DO THINK THAT
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT PROBABLY
PEOPLE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL KNOW
HOW TO DISTRIBUTE AND HOW TO
SET UP FOR START. BETTER FIGURE
OUT THAT. AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO BE OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO
STAFF UP THE END HAPPY
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE TO BE
ABLE TO DEAL WITH THIS BUT I.
QUESTION BECAUSE I THINK WE'VE
ALL DEALING WITH IT. THE ISSUE
WITH THE V. D. QUITE FRANKLY AS
WE HAD A THREE POINT 8%
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE AND SO THEY
WERE PERFECTLY STAFFED. FOR A
THREE POINT 8% UNEMPLOYMENT AND
QUITE FRANKLY IT HAD THEY HAD
TOO MANY EMPLOYEES. AT BUDGET
TIME WE WOULD HAVE BEEN SAYING
WHY WE HAVE SO MANY PEOPLE
WORKING A DVD EITHER BUDGET IS
INFLATED WE NEED TO CUT REESE
SAYS. BUT FROM A THREE POINT.
8% UNEMPLOYMENT TWO I THINK THE
NUMBER NOW IS ABOUT 15% THAT'S
HUGE IN. AND DOES. IS ALL THE
FACT THAT THERE'S BEEN SOME
HICCUPS IN IN GETTING ARE BUT
BUT WE DO IT IS IT THE REALITY
OF THE SITUATION IS THAT ALMOST
ANYWHERE WE PUT THIS IS GOING
TO BE DIFFICULT AND I HAVE NO.
NO IN. THE CITY IT'S- A
QUESTION OF HAVING THEM BE THE
ADMINISTRATORS OF A PROGRAM AND
THEN GET IT GETTING THE LOCAL
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO. TO ROLL
THIS KIND OF PROGRAM. ONE DAY
YOU'RE LOOKING AT OPTIONS AND
ALTERNATIVES- BECAUSE WE'VE GOT
THIS CAL AS WELL WHICH HAS BEEN
A BILLION DOLLAR SOFTWARE
PROBLEM- BUT I. DIDN'T DO SOME
RESEARCH. AND THE STATE OF
RHODE ISLAND. WAS ABLE TO MOVE
PAGE IT'S UNEMPLOYMENT.
IMPLOSION RATHER QUICKLY AND-
SO THEY- THEY USE SOFTWARE THAT
WAS. IN THE CAR IT WAS IT. AND
SO THEY'VE BEEN GIVING A THE
BEST IT'S PROMPTLY SO MAYBE
THERE'S SOME. THAT WE SHOULD
LOOK AT THAT TO HELP. WITH THIS
PROGRAM- THE NEXT QUESTION I
HAD. WAS SINCE FOR ESTABLISHING
A NEW- THERE WOULD REQUIRE
BUREAUCRACY BUT IT WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE A LOT OF FUNDING. SO
I'M JUST CURIOUS. EVEN THOUGH I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT A LOT OF
THESE. PEOPLE THAT WERE LAID
OFF THERE WAS SORT OF A SELF
INFLICTED BY BY THE CAPITAL SO
NEEDS TO STEP UP IN SOME WAY I
JUST DON'T KNOW WHERE THE
MONEY'S GOING TO BE COMING FROM
AND OF COURSE SHOULD HAVE FROM
THE GENERAL FUND. OKAY SO IT'S
A BUDGET PRIOR FIFTH OFFICE OF
IT TODAY BECAUSE I THINK THE
STATE HAS A RESPONSIBILITY.
BECAUSE IT KIND OF. CREATED
SOME OF THIS PROBLEM SO- BUT I
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT. HOW WE
MANAGE IT SO THAT WE JUST DON'T
FRUSTRATE A LOT OF GOOD PEOPLE
EVEN MORE I UNDERSTAND THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER.
CENTER THERE ARE. YES THANK YOU
CENTER SKINNER- ONE MILLION
PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF RHODE
ISLAND SO. IT'S QUITE A
DIFFERENCE FROM WHAT WE FACE IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT I- I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT RESPONSE THAT-
CENTER RECOVERY IT'LL JUST BE
OFF. THE AUTHOR CO AUTHOR. OF
JUST PRESENTED- I AND I
APPRECIATE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN OTHER PROPOSALS WHICH
IS- WOULD TAKE A LITTLE BIT
MORE TIME TO SOMETHING THAT'S
NEEDED RIGHT NOW- I THINK
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. IN
SAYING THAT. THE ORGANIZATIONS
ON THE GROUND- HAVE THE
EXPERIENCE NOT TO HANDLE YOU
KNOW HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE DESPERATE BUT
THEY CERTAINLY HAVE A SENSE OF
HOW TO DO IT ON THE GROUND AND
SO. I APPRECIATE THAT THE
AUTHOR IS GOING TO REACH OUT TO
THOSE ORGANIZATIONS IT'S BEST
DONE WITH THEM IN MIND ON THE
PRACTICAL SIDE OF IT- BECAUSE
ON THE ISSUE OF. WHETHER OR NOT
WE SHOULD DO THIS WE ABSOLUTELY
SHOULD DO IT. THEY'RE GOING TO
FACE IT NOW IN A LITTLE BIT
MORE ORGANIZED WAY OR WE'RE
GOING TO FACE IT ONE HUNDREDS
OF. PEOPLE ARE THEY- ALL
EVERYONE IS GOING TO- OF JUST
BE IN THAT DESPERATE MULTIPLE.
AGAIN THEM THE I THINK THE
PRIORITY IS DEFINITELY THOSE
WHO ARE THE MOST IN NEED RIGHT
AWAY AND REACH THE HEART- GET
GET TO THE HARD TO REACH
COMMUNITIES SELF EMPLOYED
UNDOCUMENTED. AND LANGUAGE
LANGUAGES THAT CALIFORNIA'S
SPEAK- SO I WILL SUPPORT THIS
AND I HOPE- THAT WE CAN- AT
LEAST FOR NOW ADDRESS SOME OF
THOSE IMMEDIATE ISSUES AND I
WOULD ERR ON THE SIDE OF- BEANS
TO IT. AND AS QUICK AS POSSIBLE
AND NOT BEING BURDEN TO
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO TAKE.
A REALLY LONG TIME AND I THINK
THAT'S WHERE YOU'RE COMING FROM
AS WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU CENTER CABALLERO.
ROSS SO- THERE ARE COMMON OR
QUESTIONS. OKAY SEEING NINE- I-
IN SUPPORT OF A MOVING IS OUT
OF COMMITTEE FOR THIS BILL-
STILL NEEDS ADDITIONAL WORK
BOTH IN TERMS OF A MECHANISM-
AND- AND OTHERWISE- TYPICALLY-
WITH THIS- STATE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN-
MOVED THROUGH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AS OPPOSED TO THE STATE. HAVING
A DIRECT RELATIONSHIP- CAN THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE SOMETIMES
IN A BETTER POSITION TO DO ITEM
AND EVEN THOUGH THERE ARE.
REASONS WHY THE HASN'T WORKED
SO WELL- THESE DAYS YOU KNOW IT
DOES SHOW THAT OUR OUR STATE
AGENCIES CAN GET OVERWHELMED.
FOR A STATE OF FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE- BUT WITH THAT SAID I
I'M I THINK WE SHOULD MOVE THIS
FORWARD- TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION. I ALSO WANT TO
KNOW AND SOME OF THE OPPOSITION
CALLERS- THIS BILL DOES NOT A
VICTIM PROTECTIONS- AND YOU
DON'T HAVE TO DO EVERYTHING ALL
IN ONE BILL THIS IS ABOUT
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE. WE DO
NEED CONTINUING STRONG
AFFECTION PROTECTIONS BECAUSE
OF WHAT ENDS UP HAPPENING IS
PEOPLE DON'T PAY THE RENT AND
ULTIMATELY GET SOME ASSISTANCE
AT SOME POINT. BUT THEY'VE
ALREADY. GOT A THREE DAY NOTICE
OR- OR WHATEVER. IT DEFEATS THE
PURPOSE I WILL NOTE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S DIRECTION- EXECUTIVE
ORDER EXPIRES ON SUNDAY. AND
OUR CITIES ARE NOT YET RENEW
THEIR LOCAL ELECTION
MORATORIUM- BECAUSE THEY'RE
WAITING FOR THE GOVERNOR. BY
THE BACK OF. THE THIS.
CONVERSATION WITH HER OF
FINDING FIVE ZERO ZERO AND I
WROTE A CIRCLE IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU MUCH
MISTER I WANT TO SAY I THANK
THAT THE TENANTS AND TENANTS
WRITER OF PURCHASE I'M I'M I
ALWAYS APPRECIATE HEARING FROM
THEM AND I'VE I'VE TAKEN NOTES-
I JUST WANT TO CALL OUT THAT
THE BILL. DOES NOT DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST AND THE SELF EMPLOYED
AN UNDOCUMENTED WE EXPECT THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE THE SAME
KIND OF DATA ABOUT THE PANDEMIC
AFFECTING THEM THAT ANYONE ELSE
WOULD HAVE BEEN SO WE EXPECT
THAT EVERYONE WILL BE ABLE TO
QUALIFY AND ALSO THAT THERE ARE
OBJECTION PROTECTIONS IN THE
BILL FOR THE POOR TO. THE
PROGRAM. BY THAT PACIFIC IS
DESIGNED TO HEY IF. YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE GONNA PARTISAN AS A
LAW. YOU GOING TO YOU'RE GOING
TO GET UP CERTAIN. AND PART OF
THAT IS THE- TO AFFECT THE
TENANTS THAT ABILITY TO GET ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT. THE INABILITY
TO GET A 100% OF THAT OF THE
RENT. AND THE OF THE ABILITY TO
RAISE THE RENT SO. WITH WITH
THAT IN MIND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
MOTION BY CENTER LIKE HEALTH
NEEDS. I WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
TEN BY SENATOR LIMA GONZALEZ
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WINNER
HI WIENER HI MORAL. MORRELL AYE
CABALLERO BY ZERO TORONTO.
DORADO MCGUIRE WATER I MORAL.
MORE LOCK I ROTH HI ROB I
SKINNER SKIN HI NUMBER NUMBER I
WOULD CAL SKI HI WHAT KIND OF
THE ARE. CAN YOU GO TO CHANGE
NOTHING OF THE BILL IS OUT BACK
OUR AGENDA FOR THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING TODAY AND WE ARE
CURRENT.